[Musik]
nach dem US-Präsident Joe Biden die
ukrainischen bitten um die App 16 mehr
als ein Jahr lang abgelehnt hatte
änderte am mai plötzlich seinen Kurs er
erklärte er unterstütze die Idee
ukrainische Piloten an den Jets
auszubilden und befürwortete die
Übergabe der Flugzeuge durch andere
Länder ich begrüße die historische
Entscheidung der Vereinigten Staaten und
des US-Präsidenten eine internationale
Kampfjet Koalition zu unterstützen dies
wird unsere Armee am Himmel erheblich
verstärken ich rechne damit die
praktische Umsetzung dieser Entscheidung
auf dem G7 Gipfel in hiroshimator
erörtern internationale Kampfjet
Koalition es handelt sich um nichts
Geringeres als eine der Hauptforderung
der Ukraine seit Beginn der Invasion da
die Fähigkeiten der ukrainischen
Luftwaffe die noch aus der Zeit das
wirklich Union stammt sehr begrenzt sind
außerdem verfügt sie nur über eine sehr
geringe Anzahl an Flugzeugen Dänemark
die Niederlande und Belgien erklärten
sich Grund dazu bereit die Ausbildung zu
leiten was in Kiew die Hoffnung weckte
dass die Flugzeuge bereits in September
den ukrainischen Luftraum verteidigen
würden bislang beschränkte sich der
westliche Beitrag zur ukrainische
Luftwaffe ja nur auf etwa 30 mit 29 aus
Polen und das war kein was nach Ansicht
zwar bedeutend aber völlig unzureichend
ist deswegen immer wieder darauf
bestanden dass man die F16 aus
US-Produktion brauche doch beiden
zögerte mehrmals grünes Licht zu geben
nun ja irgendwas hat ihn aber
schließlich dann zum Umdenken bewegt
[Musik]
Ende Mai auf dem g7-gipfel in Hiroshima
überbrachte der US-Präsident dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten endlich die
gute Nachrichten
mehr noch mittlerweile scheint es das
Pentagon mehr als eilig zu haben die USA
sagen das F16 gegen Ende des Jahres in
der Ukraine eintreffen werden die
Äußerungen signalisieren dass die
Regierung beiden ein neues Gefühl der
Dringlichkeit verspürt die
Kampfflugzeuge so schnell wie möglich zu
liefern in der Zwischenzeit hat eine
Koalition von 11 Nationen unter der
Führung von Dänemark und Niederlanden
erste Schritte unternommen und das
pilotenausbildungsprogramm in die Tat
umzusetzen europäische Amtsträger sagten
letzte Woche dass sie hoffen dass
Ausbildungsprogramm in Dänemark im
August beginnen zu können und dass ein
Ausbildungszentrum auch in Rumänien
eingerichtet werden soll das Vereinigte
Königreich wird in der Zwischenzeit in
Kürze mit den Englischunterricht der
ukrainischen Piloten beginnen der 16
Hersteller plant die Pilotenausbildung
über einen Unterauftragnehmer dracon
international zu überwachen tja woher
kam nur dieser Sinneswandel bisher war
der Westen ihre Ansicht gewesen dass die
Ukraine keine Kampfjets brauche um sich
gegen Russland zu verteidigen doch jetzt
haben alle ihre Meinung komplett
geändert aber eines kann ich euch
verraten diese Umschwung kam nicht über
Nacht und es gibt viele Fragen die sich
noch immer in der Schwebe befinden es
wird noch viele Monate dauern bis diese
Probleme gelöst sind die Frage ist also
was steckt eigentlich hinter dem
plötzlichen Umschwung beides in der
f16frage was wissen wir eigentlich über
die ukrainische Luftwaffe wie hat sie
sich bisher geschlagen woher sollen die
für die ukrainische Luftwaffe bestimmten
F16 überhaupt kommen welchen Einfluss
könnte es auf den Kriegsverlauf haben
wenn sie jetzt überall Flugzeug wie die
F6 sind verfügt handelt es sich bei
diesen Kampfjet um eine Art Joker hat er
in den Händen der Ukraine das Zeug zum
gamechanger zum Retter in der Not heute
werden wir all diese Fragen und noch
viele weitere beantworten aber zuerst
stellen wir euch einen anderen wahren
Retter aus der Not vor und zwar aus der
Not des steuerdschungels er heißt
Steuerbord und hat als Sponsor auch das
heutige Video möglich gemacht denn hast
du eigentlich gewusst dass viele
deutsche Steuerzahler jedes Jahr
Milliarden verschenken nur weil sie von
der komplexen steuerbürokratie davon
abgeschreckt werden Geld zurückzufordern
auf dass sie eigentlich Anspruch hätten
dabei würde sich durchaus lohnen sich
mal zu überwinden schließlich haben laut
Statistischen Bundesamt in den
vergangenen Jahr 12,3 Millionen Menschen
eine Steuererstattung bekommen und zwar
im Schnitt 1.95 €. ja wie wäre es aber
wenn man sich gar nicht überwinden
müsste und die Steuererstattung trotzdem
einstreichen könnte wie nun natürlich
mit Steuerbord Steuerbord ist quasi
sowas wie Chichi mit einem
steuerberatungsplugin das während es mit
dir plaudert im Hintergrund schon mal
deine Steuererklärung ausfüllt und
optimiert er führt ein durch alle
notwendigen Angaben so als würde man
über WhatsApp mit einem gewissen
Steuerberater checken und innerhalb von
20 Minuten ist die Steuererklärung
fertig und zu Übermittlung als Finanzamt
bereit komplett papierlos und digital
ist kein steuerwissen erforderlich du
kannst keine Fehler machen auch für
absolute steuerleiden wird die
Steuererklärung und eine eventuell
saftige Steuererstattung so zum Klacks
und sollte es notwendig sein unterstützt
dich auch der fachkundige menschliche
Erfolg bei Steuerbord jederzeit mit
garantierten Antwortzeiten innerhalb von
24 Stunden das beste weißt du deine
Steuererklärungen der letzten vier Jahre
noch nicht eingereicht hast kannst du
das mit Steuerbord rückwirkend erledigen
Steuerbord erledigt alles für dich du
musst dich nicht mit dem Finanzamt
auseinandersetzen alles was du brauchst
ist deine Lohnsteuerbescheinigung schon
kann es losgehen klicke einfach auf den
Link in der Videobeschreibung oder gehe
über den QR-Code den willst einblenden
damit erhältst du sogar noch 10 € Rabatt
also worauf wartest du noch tut einem
Geldbeutel etwas Gutes und fangen jetzt
gleich an so einfach steuern zu sparen
wie nie zuvor und falls auch uns etwas
gutes tun möchtest ebenfalls in der
Videobeschreibung findest du einen
Spenden Link über den du unsere Arbeit
auf freiwilliger Basis unterstützen
kannst von unserer Seite schon mal
vielen herzlichen Dank so und nun lasst
uns wieder zur F6 16 zurückkehren könnte
sie wirklich einen Game changer werden
aufgepasst
Sam aus
der Krieg in der Ukraine lässt sich
bisher in vier Phasen unterteilen die
erste Phase entspricht den ersten beiden
Monaten viele von euch werden sich daran
erinnern wie Russland zu Beginn schnell
aufgiert zu stürmte um die Regierung der
Ukraine zu stürzen damit ist der Kreml
jedoch sang und klanglos gescheitert
erfolgreicher war er im Süden und Osten
der Ukraine wo seine Truppen damals
bedeutende Fortschritte machten die
russische Luftwaffe wird bitte sich in
dieser Phase der Bombardierung der
wichtigsten ukrainischen
Verteidigungsanlagen gegen Luftangriffe
wie Radaranlagen einige Flugplätze zum
Glück für Kiel hat der us-geheimnis
seine Arbeit ausgezeichnet gemacht und
die Ukraine rechtzeitig vor den
russischen Angriffen informiert dies
ermöglichte es den Verteidigung ihr
Arsenal und ihre Ausrüstung so über das
Land zu verteilen dass die Verluste
minimiert wurden dies waren
entscheidender Schachzug denn auf diese
Weise konnten Flugzeuge Hubschrauber und
bewaffnete Drohnen vor den ersten
Angriffen der Invasion gerettet werden
sie konnten anschließend zum Angriff auf
die russischen Kolonnen genutzt werden
die selbstbewusst und sie getrunken auf
Gier zu steuerten die lang erwartete
Überlegenheit der russischen
Streitkräfte hat sich am Boden nicht
eingestellt unsere Überraschung fast
alle auch nicht am Himmel
denn Videos und schmerzhaft erfahren
mussten brachte das Eindringen in den
ukrainischen Luftraum viele zusätzliche
Risiken mit sich dies liegt vor allem
daran dass die Luftverteidigung schon
bei sowjetischen Streitkräften eine
traditionelle Stärke darstellte auf die
man besonders Augenmerk legt legte das
bedeutet dass sowohl Russland als auch
die Ukraine über eine große Zahl recht
leistungsfähiger Luftabwehrsysteme
verfügten tatsächlich verfügte die
Ukraine über die zweitgrößte Dichte an
solchen Systemen in ganz Europa
wahrscheinlich die zweitgrößte nach
Russland hinzukommen man Pets tragbare
Luftabwehrsysteme wie ekler und Stinger
über die die Ukraine schon zu Beginn der
Invasionen großer Zahl verfügte all dies
führte zu mehr als erheblichen Verlusten
für die russische Luftwaffe und machte
es Putins horten im Grunde unmöglich die
vollständige Kontrolle über den
ukrainischen Luftraum zu übernehmen
[Musik]
für alle zukünftigen Pläne des Kreml
hatte es extrem schwerwiegende
Konsequenzen das ist eben schon so
beginnt der Invasion nicht gelungen ist
die ukrainische Luftabwehr auszuschalten
anschließend zwischen April und August
2022 konzentrierten die Russen ihre
Offensive auf die Don bassregion und
dann begann die dritte Phase des Krieges
mit der ukrainischen gegen Offensive im
Sommer 22 die befreiungsgruppen
erzielten bis November auch mit
Unterstützung ihrer Luftwaffe bedeutende
Fortschritte ganz genau mit Hilfe jeder
Luftwaffe die Russland zuvor nicht hatte
zerstören können dies bedeutet dass der
Luft Kampf zwischen den Flugzeugen
beider Seiten wieder aufgenommen wurde
Russland seinerseits verstärkte seine
Raketenangriffe auf die Ukraine dennoch
war der Frontverlauf bis zur aktuellen
ukrainischen dezember und Juni fast
völlig zum Stillstand gekommen und in
dieser vierten Phase hat Russland
weiterhin darauf gesetzt die
ukrainischen Flugabwehr Ressourcen mit
seiner Raketen und Drohnen zu erschaffen
sie setzten schlicht und einfach darauf
so viele echte wie auch täuschraketen zu
verballern dass sie damit die
Kapazitäten der ukrainischen Sams
erschöpfen für diejenigen unter euch die
jetzt nicht wissen sam ist ein Akronym
für surface to air-messeil also
Bodenluft Rakete die Ukraine verfügte
wie gesagt über eine regelrechtes
Arsenal an Sam's aus das vorwärtszeit
das im Laufe des Krieges aber immer
weiter erschöpft wurde
seit Monaten hatte selensky vom Besten
das Beste aus besten Beständen gefordert
allen voran die modernsten
Flugabwehrsysteme der Welt wie Patrick
und iresty denn eines ist klar wenn das
Fliegen über der Ukraine weniger
gefährlich werden würde könnte Russland
natürlich die Luft Überlegenheit
erlangen und dann wären praktisch alle
Chancen der Ukraine ihre Territorium
zurück zu erobern dahin genau deswegen
wurden sich die Verbündeten der Ukraine
diesen Punkt viel schneller einig USA
schicken Patrick Raketensysteme und
Panzer schneller als ursprünglich
geplant in die Ukraine nur nachdem er
die Abrams Leoparden und patrius
bekommen hatte kam die Zeit für seine
lenskys weiteren großen Wunsch die F16
Kampfjets
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben bereits in einem früheren
Video berichtet dass beiden grünes Licht
für die Ausbildung ukrainischer Piloten
für diesen Flug gegeben hat obwohl es
gar nicht so lange her war dass er
selbstbestritten hatte dass die Ukraine
eigene F16 brauche seht euch zum
Beispiel dieses ABC News Interview von
Februar 2023 an ist
[Musik]
und an dieser Stelle werden sich einige
von euch vielleicht fragen wenn der
Krieg in der Ukraine schon seit so
vielen Monaten eine partsituation
gleicht was zum Teufel ist dann passiert
dass das Weiße Haus in nur drei Monaten
seine Meinung geändert hat nun wir
vielleicht bis zitieren wir nur ungern
aus obskuren Quellen wie den angeblich
geliebten pentagon-paid was von Anfang
April zumindest nicht dann wenn wir
solche Informationen nicht anderweitig
bestätigen oder logisch begründen können
die geliebten Dokumente behaupteten
damals das Gleichgewicht im ukrainischen
Luftraum drohe zu Gunsten Russland zu
kippen seht euch an geliebte Pentagon
Dokumente waren das der Ukraine immer
die Luft Abwehr ausgehen könnte tja aber
unabhängig davon ob diese Info nun auf
Tatsachen beruht oder nicht seit diese
Nachricht die Runde machte waren die
Meinungen im Westen plötzlich geteilt
einige argumentier ten dass die Ukraine
mehr Luftabwehrsysteme vom Typ Patrick
oder Nation benötige aber so zweifelhaft
die leaks auch waren durch sie kam
Bewegung in die Sache und immer mehr
Stimmen waren der Meinung dass hier
dringend mit Kampfflugzeugen
ausgestattet werden müssen und dann
stellte sich die Frage welche konkreten
Konsequenzen könnte die F 16 in den
Händen der Ukraine haben genau das
werden wir jetzt unter die Lupe nehmen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieses Videos
im August 2023 ist der Ukraine dank des
bestens noch nicht die Luftabwehr
ausgegangen aber der russische Druck aus
der Luft hält an und fakt ist dass die
Ukraine ihre Luft Abwehr nicht überall
in ausreichend hoher Konzentration
vorhalten kann so gelingt es den
russischen Invasoren immer wieder Lücken
in ihr zu entdecken und auszunutzen mit
fatalen Folgen für die Zivilbevölkerung
aber auch für die gegen Offensive und
sollten der Ukraine die Sams gab
wirklich ausgehen haben die russischen
Flugzeuge freie Hand die Ukraine nach
Gusto zu bombardieren aber selbst wenn
diese nur knapp würden müsste sie
letztes Regierung vermehrt schmerzhafte
Prioritäten setzen und sich zwischen dem
Schutz von Städten Infrastruktur
Militärbasen oder den an der
frontstationierten Truppen entscheiden
so und jetzt kommt der klug theoretisch
könnten Kampfjets die Boden gestützte
Luftabwehr ersetzen um feindliche
Flugzeuge Helikopter Drohnen und
Muskelkörper abzuschießen natürlich hat
die ukrainische Luftwaffe bisher
versucht dies mit ihren Flugzeugen zu
erreichen nach Angaben des us-generals
James Hacker Leute die doch alles darauf
hin dass der 18 Konflikt bei der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe einen Tribut zu
fordern beginnt die Ukraine hat bei der
russischen Invasion 60 Flugzeuge
verloren und 70 abgeschossen sagt Hacker
okay auf den ersten Blick könnte man
denken na das ist doch gar nicht so
schlecht oder die Ukrainer scheinen
nicht so viele Flugzeuge verloren zu
haben und sie haben mehr abgeschossen
aber das Problem ist dass diese 60
verlorenen Kampfflugzeuge nicht weniger
als 40% der ukrainischen Luftwaffe aus
der Vorkriegszeit darstellen die Ukraine
verfügt nur noch über etwa 80 Flugzeuge
im Vergleich zu den fast 500 die der
Kreml für diesen Konflikt bereitgestellt
hat und neben der überwältigenden
zahlenmäßigen Überlegenheit verfügen die
russischen Flugzeuge auch noch über ein
besseres Radar und Munition mit größerer
Reichweite und vielleicht fragte euch an
dieser Stelle wenn dem so ist wieso
beherrschen die Russen nicht schon
längst den gesamten Himmel über der
Ukraine nun der Grund warum es ihnen in
den 18 Monaten seit Beginn der Invasion
nicht gelungen ist die Lufthoheit über
der Ukraine zu erlangen ist eben die
exzellente ukraineische Luftabwehr
da die Russen ist bisher nicht geschafft
haben diese auszuschalten sind die
russischen Bomber nun gezwungene Raketen
und Bomben aus einer beträchtlichen
Entfernung abzuschießen oder abzuwerfen
was ihre Wirksamkeit und Präzision stark
vermindert und vergesst bitte nicht dass
es sich noch immer um russische Waffen
handelt natürlich setzt der Kreml auch
bewaffnete Drohnen ein die russische
landzeit Drohne zum Beispiel gilt als
Leopard und abbrems Killer bei vielen
handelt es sich aber um die berühmten
iranischen Shahid 136 die zwei Fliegen
mit einer Klappe treffen nämlich die
Sams die Luftabwehr der Ukraine und die
wirtschaftliche Kapazität den Krieg zu
bewältigen und Drohnen aus iranischer
Produktion Kosten in der Herstellung nur
20.000 aber es kostet bis zu 500.000 um
sie abzuschießen dies ruft laut einem
Bericht in der Ukraine zunehmend
Besorgnis hervor ganz zu schweigen von
den Patricks der Stadt eine einzigen
dieser Raketen kann bis zu 4 Millionen
Dollar kosten kein echtes Schnäppchen
der Abschluss von 40 kann sogar bis zu
160 Millionen Dollar verschlingen
ziemlich verrückt nicht wahr wie ihr
euch vorstellen könnt gibt es keine
Wirtschaft die diesem Ausgaben Tempo
standhalten kann es sei denn man heißt
Uncle Sam die Option Kampfflugzeuge zur
Neutralisierung von Angriffen durch
luftbodenraketen und Drohnen einzusetzen
erscheint also vor allem aus
wirtschaftlicher Sicht durchaus sinnvoll
denn deren Einsatz ist immer noch
günstiger das Hauptproblem der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe ist jedoch dass
ihre Radarsysteme an Bord veraltet sind
hier verfügt über mit 29 und su27 aus
der Sowjet Zeit und Polen und sich
Slowakei haben den Land weitere mit 29
zur Verfügung gestellt doch im
konfrontationsfall bei einer
tatsächlichen Gegenüberstellung können
diese Flugzeuge der russischen Luftwaffe
nicht das Wasser reichen zum Vergleich
das Radar einer modernen russischen su
35 hat eine Reichweite von 200 km das
der mit 29 von nur 70 km eine ist also
klar die Ukraine braucht dringend eine
neue Flotte von Kampfjets und genau hier
kommt die F16 ins Spiel es handelt sich
um nichts Geringeres als das Rückgrat
der NATO Luftstreitkräfte der letzten 40
Jahre ihre Einführung wurde die
ukrainische Luftwaffe entscheidend
ergänzen da sie ihr etwas Neues bringen
würde Mobilität
[Musik]
vom Flugzeuge können eine größere Zahl
von Zielen in weiteren Radius schützen
indem sie sich schnell über das Gebiet
bewegen außerdem kann ein Flugzeug
gerade auf unter Erdkrümmung fliegende
Objekte in größere Entfernung erkennen
als ein Boden gestütztes hinzu kommt
natürlich dass das Radar der F16
wesentlich leistungsfähiger ist als dass
der Nick 29
[Musik]
der wahre gamechanger ist jedoch das was
unter den Flügeln der F16 hängen könnte
die F16 ist ohne weiteres mit einem
gigantischen Katalog von Raketen und
Bomben kompatibel die von den USA und
anderen Verbündeten Ukraine in großen
Mengen geliefert werden können sobald
die ersten F16 einsatzbereit wären das
breite Spektrum an Einsatzzwecken der
F16 Waffen reicht von
Hochgeschwindigkeit
antistrahlungsraketen zur
Neutralisierung des feindlichen Radars
über gleitbomben und schissabwehrraketen
bis zu einem riesigen Arsenal von
Marschflugkörpern für Bodenangriffe das
Wichtigste an dieser Munition ist jedoch
dass sie eine sehr große Reichweite
haben kann insbesondere der tank-
Muskelkörper joint er zur surface
standoffen ja SSM kein russische Truppen
und anderes Ziel aus hunderten von
Kilometern Entfernung
glücklich darüber sie an den
ukrainischen Verbündeten liefern zu
können eine F60 Staffel mit
langstreckenmunition könnte russische
Ziele in der gesamten von Russland
besetzten Ukraine einschließlich der
Halbinsel Grimm ang sie könnte russische
kriegs- und Transportschiffe in ihren
Häfen oder in weiten Teilen des
schwarzes Meeres eliminieren und sie
könnte diese Raketen abfeuern ohne
jemals den relativ sicheren Ukrainisch
kontrollierten Luftraum verlassen zu
müssen doch damit wäre die Ukraine nicht
nur in der Lage im Falle der Belagerung
der Krimi die russische Versorgung übers
Wasser abzuschneiden nein sie könnte
auch eine ganz bestimmte Waffe Kontern
die sich im Rahmen der jetzigen gegen
Offensive als besonders tödliche Joker
des Kreml erwiesen hat von welcher
russischen Waffe hier die Rede ist nun
von dieser hier 16 Juni 2023 Gabor
Russlands K A 42 Alligator Jagd 2
ukrainische Panzer mit neuen
visiersystem und Raketen der russische
Kampfhubschrauber kam auf ka 52
Alligator hat sich offenbar als bester
panzerkiller entpuppt ein weiteres Video
zeigt wie er im Süden von Don jetzt zwei
ukrainische Panzer durch den Abschluss
von luftgestützten Panzerabwehrraketen
vernichtet dies geschieht inmitten der
enthusiastischen Gegend Offensive der
Ukraine die bereits zahlreiche Leopard
Panzer aus deutscher Produktion und
mehrere amerikanische Fahrzeuge verloren
hat schon zu Beginn ihrer gegen
Offensive unternahmen die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte eine Reihe von
sondierungsvorstößen um die stärksten
widerstandsfaktoren der Russen zu
identifizieren ganz oben auf ihrer
konterliste hat sich dabei der
Kampfhubschrauber ka 52 festgesetzt ja
es stimmt das auch diese Typ bereits zu
Beginn der russischen Invasion die
Fallobst vom ukrainischen Himmel geholt
wurde allein am 24 Februar 2022 den
ersten Tag des Angriffs verloren die
russische Luftwaffe 6 Kampfhubschrauber
darunter 2ka 52 seitdem haben die
russischen Streitkräfte fast 20 dieser
Maschinen im Kampfeinsatz verloren
gleichzeitig tauchten jedoch erste
Fragen auf warum dies überhaupt geschah
und der erste Grund ist leicht zu
verstehen und heißt die tragbaren Flug
Abwehrsysteme mit sehr kurzer Reichweite
dies hängt mit der einsatzbestimmung der
KS 250 zusammen dieser Hubschrauber ist
in erster Linie zur abwehrfeindliche
Panzer Angriffe gedacht und unterstützt
auch die Infanterie in dem er
Panzerabwehrraketen aus relativ geringer
Entfernung abhefeuert dies macht die kam
auf zwei offensiv-operation jedoch zum
perfekten Ziel sowohl für tragbare
Raketensysteme als auch für Waffen mit
Mündungsfeuer wie Maschinengewehre hinzu
kommt eine bestimmte Achillesferse beim
Flugverhalten zwar beeinträchtigte
Rückstoß an der Waffen das Flugverhalten
des Hubschraubers nicht wesentlich
allerdings muss der Pilot vor dem Feuer
langsamer fliegen damit das Zielsystem
das zielinsivision nehmen kann und nach
dem feuern dauert es eine Weile bis er
wieder an Geschwindigkeit gewinnt doch
so sehr die KA 52 zu Beginn des Krieges
aufgrund dieser Schwächen auch
verspottet worden sein mag ist sie
während der ukrainischen gegen Offensive
zu einem entscheidenden konterfaktor
geworden anders als während der
verteidigungsphase kann die ukrainische
elefanterie mit ihrem Mann Pads nicht
vorstörungen um die Panzer zu schützen
also können die camo Hubschrauber jetzt
aus sicherer Entfernung auf die
ukrainischen Panzerkolonnen ich meine es
ist sowieso schon ein Husarenstück dass
die Ukraine einen Boden gestützte gegen
Offensive ohne nennenswerte
Luftunterstützung durchführt keine NATO
Armee und auch nicht die Russen wären
dazu in der Lage und jetzt ratet mal
womit ließe sich das Paar 250 Probleme
lösen genau mit der F16 und ihren
Langstreckenraketen dann würden die
russischen Hubschrauber wieder ganz
schnell vom Himmel fallen bevor sie auch
nur einen ukrainischen Panzer gefährden
könnten das Problem die Entscheidung für
die Lieferung der F16 und die Ausbildung
der Piloten kam für diese gegen
Offensive viel zu spät leider eines der
prominentesten Beispiele wie stark die
zögerliche Haltung des Westens die
Anstrengung der Ukraine unterkriegt den
Krieg in die Länge zieht und unzählige
zusätzliche Menschenleben kostet denn
erst mit den grünen Licht aus Washington
zeigen sich auch die ersten
Schwierigkeiten die eigentlich hätte
schon viel früher gelöst werden können
Verzögerungen und Ungewissheit bei der
App 16 Ausbildung für ukrainische
Piloten eine erste Gruppe von sechs
ukrainischen Piloten wird die Ausbildung
auf den USA hergestellten erst 16
voraussichtlich nicht vor dem nächsten
Sommer abschließen dies berichten
hochrangige ukrainische
regierungs-westlichen
Ausbildungsprogramm für den entwickelten
Kampfjet nachdem der Beginn der
Ausbildung mehrmals verschoben wurde
wird die Ukraine nun wahrscheinlich ein
weiteres Jahr ohne die kampflieger
auskommen müssen von denen
Verantwortliche in Kiew eine bedeutende
militärischen Vorteil in einer langsam
verlaufenden Gegenoffensive und eine
bessere Schuss der Zivilbevölkerung vor
den regelmäßigen russischen Raketen und
Drohnenangriffen erhoffen und es drohen
weitere Probleme eines davon ist dass
die F16 zum Starten lange und glatte
Landebahn benötigen es überrascht nicht
dass man darüber auch schon im Kreml
Bescheid weiß Russland führt
gruppenraketenangriff auf Ziele auf
ukrainischen Militärflugplätzen durch
eine Alternative wäre die Nutzung
verstreuter und improvisierter
Flugplätze deren Zahl könnte höher sein
und sie wären für die Russen schwerer zu
finden aber natürlich werden die
Landebahn kürzer und unwegsamer mit
anderen Worten viel gefährlicher man
kann nur hoffen dass die künftigen
ukrainischen 16 Piloten genau jenes
improvisationsgeschick an den Tag legen
wie es auch ihre Kameraden in den
anderen Waffengattungen bewiesen haben
[Musik]
natürlich untermauert das Problem mit
den Start- und Landebahnen die
Argumentation derjenigen die behaupten
die Ukraine brauche er mehr Artillerie
Panzer und Sams als Kampfjets ihrer
Meinung nach muss man militärische
Ressourcen in jenen Bereichen
konzentrieren wo sie die größte Wirkung
entfalten manche befürchten auch dass
die Lieferung von F16 an die Ukraine zu
einer Eskalation des Konflikt führen
könnte dies wurde von beiden selbst
ausgeschlossen der versicherte dass die
F16 nur zur Verteidigung der Ukraine
nicht zum Angriff auf Russland dienen
würde
from the man
bisher hat sich die Ukraine immer daran
gehalten wenn sie versprochen hat an Sie
gelieferte Waffen nur für bestimmte
Zwecke einzusetzen letztlich dürfen wir
aber auch nicht vergessen dass wir hier
über einen Flugzeugtyp sprechen der
Seite
1978 in Betrieb ist dem Jahr in dem der
Film grease in die Kinos kam also auch
wenn das 2012er Upgrade Viper durchaus
mit allen modernen russischen Kampfjets
mithalten kann nein die F 16 ist nicht
gerade der neueste Meilenstein im
Luftkampf und es sieht nicht so aus als
würde Ihre Lieferung an die Ukraine die
nukleare Apokalypse auslösen außerdem
hat sich das Weiße Haus sehr clever
Verhalten in dem ist den G7 Gipfel
benutzte um die Freigabe der Lieferung
an die Ukraine zu verkünden hat beiden
seine Verbündeten an diese Entscheidung
gebunden und an dieser Stelle kommt die
internationale Kampfjet Koalition ins
Spiel was wird sie über das bereits
genannte bewirken nun spricht jetzt die
Ohren wenn hier kommt der
interessanteste part
[Musik]
der ukrainische himmelsschild
die Unterstützung der USA für die
Kampfjet Koalition ist insofern von
entscheidender Bedeutung als eine Export
von 116 kam Flugzeugen in die Ukraine
das Einverständnis unbedingt
erforderlich ist auch wenn diese
Kampfflugzeuge derzeit anderen Ländern
gehören so legen es eben die
us-waffenexportbestimmungen Fest der
Koalition gehören mehrere europäische
Länder an und obwohl sie noch keinen
offiziellen Namen hat hat selenski
seinen eigenen Vorschlag eingebracht und
hey Marvel hätte es sich nicht besser
ausdenken können
die Kampfjet Koalition das Treffen mit
den Führern der europäischen Länder wie
erörterten Fragen im Zusammenhang mit
dem Beginn der Ausbildung von Piloten
auf F16 und anderen Flugzeugtypen wir
sind übereingekommen die Arbeit an einer
offiziellen Entscheidung zur Schaffung
der ukrainischen Sky Shield Kampfjet
Koalition
vorzusetzenski mit einem anderen
Flugzeugtyp Mainz Zielinski
wahrscheinlich den schwedischen Schweden
verfügt über etwa 100 dieser Jets die
sehr einfach zu warten und zu bedienen
sind und die auch auf kurzen Landebahnen
starten können sie wären eigentlich
ideal für die Ukraine aber bis Schweden
endlich in die NATO aufgenommen wird
kann es keinen davon entbehren entgegen
wurden inzwischen seit Beginn der
Produktion in den 70er Jahren mehr als
4.6 16 Maschinen gebaut einige pro Jahr
werden immer noch in South Carolina
produziert und die USA planen ihre
neuesten Modelle noch zwei Jahrzehnte
lang einsatzbereit zu halten aber es
gibt Länder die planen Sie zu ersetzen
sobald die neuen F-35 eintreffen gewöhnt
euch also schon mal an Nachrichten wie
diese die Niederlande werden nach der
Pilotenausbildung wahrscheinlich erst 16
in die Ukraine schicken die Niederlande
genauso wie Dänemark und Belgien zählen
zu den Hauptakteuren des ukrainischen
Himmels zu diesen zählt auch
Großbritannien aber es verfügt selbst
über keine F16 genauso wie zum Beispiel
auch Deutschland nicht eine Möglichkeit
wäre aber das London sie von anderen
Ländern kauft um sie dann der Ukraine zu
übergeben
die deutschen verfügen nur über
veraltete Tornados und zu komplexe
Eurofighter die für den Einsatz in der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe ungeeignet wären
trotzdem könnten sie auch hier einen
Beitrag leisten die jetzt 16 sind
kurzfristig verfügbar sie sind relativ
leicht in der Handhabung und es gibt
noch endlos Ersatzteile gefragt sind
daher zunächst die Nationen die überall
16 verfügen nicht erst 16 Nationen
können natürlich einen Beitrag leisten
mit ausbildungsunterstützung gerade wenn
es um die Erstausbildung von Piloten
geht mit der Grundlagenausbildung oder
die zur Verfügung stellen von
Flugplätzen auch bei der Munition gibt
es Möglichkeiten der Unterstützung
generell und Ingo Gerhards
luftwaffeninfektion der Bundeswehr an
dieser Stelle sollten wir jedoch mal
kurz Inhalten und noch mal zur
ressourcenfrage zurückkommen denn auch
wenn es vorhin so klang als sei die App
16 eine kostengünstigere Lösungen als
z.B Patriot so ist die alles andere als
ein Schnäppchen die Bereitstellung von F
16 wird für die Verbündeten eine neue
große wirtschaftliche Herausforderung
darstellen hört euch mal die Schätzungen
von colinhalle an dem
us-unterstaatssekretär für
verteidigungspol
darüber hinaus gibt es auch andere
europäische Länder die für den
ukrainischen himmelsschild von zentraler
Bedeutung sein werden so deutet alles
darauf hin dass die Wartung der 16
zunächst in Polen und Rumänien
durchgeführt werden könnte also in den
an die Ukraine angrenzenden NATO-Ländern
die diesen Flugzeugtyp bereits einsetzen
Rumänien ist in letzter Zeit sogar
besonders in den Blickpunkt gerückt man
einen Blick hier auf der besten
betrachtet Rumänien als möglichen F16
Ausbildungsort für ukrainische Piloten
die Tatsache dass die Ausbildung der
Piloten und vor allem die Wartung der 16
auf nahtoderatorium stattfinden würde
bedeutet dass sie theoretisch gut vor
russischen Raketen geschützt sind
etwas das den Kreml ganz Ungarn nicht
gefallen dürfte deswegen hat Putin
bereits eine üblichen Drohungen
ausgestoßen damit die gerettet
ohne Lehrer
aber das ist ja wahrlich nichts Neues
also was ist eigentlich unser Fazit nun
die Entscheidung für die F16 Lieferung
und die Ausbildung der Piloten sind ein
wichtiges Zeichen aber sie kamen viel zu
spät während der Gegend Offensive der
Ukraine hat sich gezeigt das ist
notwendig ist nicht erst im Nachhinein
zu reagieren wenn ein Problem wie zum
Beispiel der Kampfhubschrauber Kart 52
auftaucht viel mehr ist es im Kriegsfall
wie auch davor wichtig für so viele
Möglichkeiten wie nur möglich Reserven
vorzuhalten und ihren Aufbau rechtzeitig
vorzubereiten ich meine was hätte es
gekostet was hätte man riskiert wenn
wenigstens die Pilotenausbildung schon
im vorigen Jahr erlaubt worden wäre fakt
ist nämlich wenn schon während der
aktuellen gegen Offensive F16 zur
Verfügung gestanden hätten wäre ihr
Erfolg viel sicherer und weniger
kostspielig sowohl was Ressourcen als
auch Menschen leben und Zeit angeht die
Ukraine hätte das russische
kriegspotential viel weiterdefinieren
Können und viel mehr ihre Territoriums
befreien können aber so könnte es sein
dass ich aufgrund der Unentschlossenheit
des Westens und sein rationalen Angst
vor Putins roten Linien der Krieg um ein
weiteres Jahr verlängern muss aber was
meint ihr glaubt ihr dass die F16
entscheiden sein wird um Russland zu
besiegen oder denkt ihr dass diese
Kampfflugzeuge zu einer großen
Eskalation des Konflikts führen könnten
welche anderen Waffensysteme müssten der
Ukraine dringend zur Verfügung gestellt
werden sollten wir über diese eventuell
auch ein eigenes Video drehen wie immer
sind wir auf eure Diskussion und Eure
Anregungen zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja geht
uns bitte ein Leid als mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert ist mit ihnen
natürlich von uns auch jederzeit immer
eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]